der erste kranken computer mit mehr als
5.000 jupitz in europa der sogenannte
quanten ära der jetzt im nordrhein
westfälischen forschungszentrum jülich
an den start gegangen es ist ein echter
meilenstein für die entwicklung des
quantencomputers es handelt sich um das
erste quantencomputer system überhaupt
das für industrielle anwendungen
konzipiert wurde und noch mehr bau in
jülich wird ein eigener kranken computer
entwickelt klicks um science in
future.de bis dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
das ist ein riesending deutschland holte
in sachen quanten computing auf mit
januar ist am forschungszentrum jülich
ein neuer besonders leistungsfähiger
quantenrechner in betrieb genommen
worden der rechner wurde von einer
kanadischen firma gebaut und verfügt
über 5000 quantenbits das ist eine echte
premiere
nicht nur für deutschland sondern ganz
europa denn bei der leistungsfähigen
maschine handelt es sich somit um den
ersten kranken computer mit mehr als
5.000 cubes außerhalb nordamerikas super
komplexe rechenleistung werden damit
möglich und diese sollen für
verschiedene forschungsbereiche genutzt
werden unter anderem für die
klimaforschung was kann der jüdischer
kanten computer wirklich und wie weit
ist deutschland in sachen
quantencomputer die antworten auf diese
spannenden fragen und noch viel mehr
gibt es jetzt hier bei pixum science im
flugzeug
quantencomputer bieten enorme chancen
für unsere zukunft und den
forschungsstandort deutschland
sie haben das potenzial unserem alltag
zum besseren zu verändern etwa mit blick
auf die optimale nutzung und so
stromnetzes der optimierung von
anlagestrategien am finanzmarkt oder
die sein wirksamere medikamente so die
bundesforschungsministerin bettina stark
watzinger bei der inbetriebnahme des
neuen quantencomputers am
forschungszentrum jülich und tatsächlich
kranken computer könnten die größten
probleme unserer zeit angehen und
möglicherweise sogar lösen weltweit
werden derzeit systeme entwickelt die
sowohl für die forschung als auch für
die industrie
revolutionär sein die quantentechnologie
könnten nicht nur die klimaforschung
nach vorne bringen und uns eine
abhörsichere kommunikation ermöglichen
auch die planung von verkehrs flüssen in
echtzeit die entwicklung neuer
medizinischer wirkstoffe oder die
analyse komplexer vorgänge an
finanzmärkten könnten einen enormen
sprung nach vorne machen ohne zu
übertreiben könnte man sagen dass die
nächste industrielle revolution
möglicherweise also solch
quantencomputer ausgelöst werden könnte
davon träumen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler weltweit vor drei jahren
2009/10 haben google fachleute einem
quantencomputer entwickelt der mit 53
tubes in 2 100 sekunden eine aufgabe
gelöst hat für die ein gewöhnlicher
supercomputer tausende von jahren
benötigt hätte viele fachleute
bezeichnet das als den beginn der
quantencomputer er damals wurde zum
ersten mal die quanten überlegenheit
erreicht ein quantencomputer war damit
jedem existierenden computer überlegen
zwar bei einer sehr speziellen aufgabe
aber immerhin die leistungsfähigen
maschinen funktionieren anders als wir
es von konventionellen computern kennen
klassische computer arbeiten mit bits
die jeweils nur zwei zustände annehmen
können 1 und grün also an und ausziehen
quasi schalter kleine anders dagegen bei
den kranken computer sie basieren auf
den so genannten quanten bits kurz kibiz
die beiden werte gleichzeitig annehmen
können theoretisch können sie sogar
unendlich viele zustände dazwischen
annehmen und zwar gleichzeitig und so
sind sie in der lage unglaublich viele
mögliche lösungen zur selben zeit durch
rechnung zu können in einem fanden
physikalischen system sind
beispielsweise ionen also fand und bis
kurz jukic die kleinste rechnereinheit
das ganze ist der teil der quantenwelt
die die wissenschaft bereits seit vielen
jahren fasziniert das phänomen der
verschränkung erlaubte es den zustand
von teilchen wie atom millionen oder
photonen zu koppeln ganz egal wie weit
diese voneinander entfernt sind und
sobald sich der zustand des ein
teilchens ändert gibt es auch beim
verschränken partner teilchen einen
zustands wechsel und genau das ist die
basis für viele super praktische
anwendungen der quantenphysik und davon
ist der quantencomputer nur ein
quantencomputer basieren also auf den
vorteilen die quanten physikalische
phänomene wie überlagerung und
verschränkung mit sich bringen eine
spannende premiere gibt es eben jetzt am
forschungszentrum im nordrhein
westfälischen jülich hier wurde jetzt im
jahr 2022 der erste quantencomputer mit
mehr als 5.000 jukic außerhalb von
nordamerika in betrieb genommen konkret
handelt es sich bei advantage um einen
kommerziellen konnten rechner der von
der kanadischen firma die wave
entwickelt wurde das erste
quantencomputer system überhaupt das für
industrielle anwendungen konzipiert
wurde für viele forschende und
politikerinnen und politiker markiert
das einen meilenstein für die
entwicklung des quanten computings
europa konkret handelt sie sich bei dem
jeglicher hochleistungsrechner um einen
so genannten quanten emil diese art von
quantensystemen hatten fachleute als
besonders geeignet für die lösung von
schwierigen optimierungs problemen mit
vielen variablen diese treten
beispielsweise bei der nutzung von
stromnetzen der berechnung von
verkehrsflüsse und der optimierung von
anlagestrategien am finanzmarkt auf
mögliche anwendungsbereiche verwandte
sind zum beispiel die komplexe analyse
von umfangreichen daten wie es sie
beispielsweise in der klimaforschung um
teilchen für sie gibt auch ein training
von künstlichen neuronalen netzen der
künstlichen intelligenz ist angedacht
viele dieser bereiche sind auch für die
industrie von großem interesse nicht nur
verschiedene forschungsteams aus europa
sollen also zugriff auf den jüdischer
kanten rechner bekommen sondern auch
entwicklungsteams aus der industrie
deswegen wird advantage in die
bestehende infrastruktur für
quantencomputer in jülich unique
integriert die abkürzung unique steht
für jüdischer nutzer infrastruktur für
quantencomputer aus ganz europa sollen
entsprechende person ein zugriff auf den
nokia quantenrechner haben können aber
eben auch auf die supercomputer fort
besondere synergieeffekte sollen so
entstehen und entsprechend schwierige
optimierungs probleme durchgerechnet
werden können dazu der direktor des
jülich supercomputing centre
thomas lippert wir untersuchen auch
möglichkeiten das neue system in unsere
supercomputer infrastruktur zu
integrieren was nach unserem wissen der
erste fall wäre in dem ein
quantencomputer indirekt mit einem
supercomputer zusammen dies ist möglich
weil der anlieger über 5000 jubels
besitzt und daher groß genug ist um bei
anwendungsbezogenen und leben zu helfen
wie sie auf supercomputern gerechnet
werden die erwartungen sind also riesig
doch wenn man es ganz genau nimmt
handelt es sich bei advantage gar nicht
um einen quantenrechner im strengen
sinne denn dazu müssten laut
definitionen die quantenphysikalischen
rechten anhalten einzeln angesprochen
und zu logischen gattern
zusammengeschaltet werden können bei
advantage ist das etwas anders hier
befinden sich möglichst viele kubitz in
einer art kollektiven überlagerung bei
einer laufenden berechnung streben sie
den zustand der geringsten energie an
wenn dieser dann erreicht ist liegt das
ergebnis vor deswegen die korrekte
bezeichnung des kranken anlass damit das
kannten computersystem etwa jetzt in
jülich an den start gehen konnte war
einiges an vorbereitung notwendig denn
wie alle kranken computer benötigt er
einen vibrationsfreien standort in
jülich wurden deswegen ein neues gebäude
mit zwei hallen gebaut das auf
erschütterungsfrei fundamenten steht
außerdem ist es notwendig dass die
prozessoren gekühlt werden doch wie
advantage im detail funktioniert wird
wohl nie jemand erfahren
betriebsgeheimnis doch er bietet
deutschland eine riesige chance die
möglichkeiten des quantencomputers
können ganz genau ausgelotet werden und
fachkompetenz aufgebaut werden und das
ist auch dringend nötig denn in sachen
quantencomputer hat nicht nur
deutschland selbst sondern ganz europa
dringend nachholbedarf zwei milliarden
euro an finanziellen mitteln hatte die
vorherige bundesregierung bereits
gestellt damit deutschland nicht den
anschluss verliert das ziel mindestens
einen leistungsfähigen quantencomputer
made in germany in den kommenden fünf
jahren zu bauen beispielsweise in jülich
selbst wird seit einiger zeit einen
eigener quantencomputer entwickelt das
system open super crew soll laut plan im
endausbau über rund 100 rannten bis
verfügen eine open source software soll
es ermöglichen dass im prinzip jede und
jeder auf den quantencomputer zugreifen
kann im vergangenen jahr 2021 war der
erste kommerzielle quantencomputer in
europa an den start gegangen und zwar in
stuttgart unter leitung der
fraunhofer-gesellschaft es handelt sich
um das ibm-system cubes ist man laut der
ehemaligen bundeskanzlerin und
physikerin angela merkel ein wunderwerk
der technologie das erklärte ziel im
wettstreit mit china und den usa
bestehen zu können dass deutsche
bundesforschungsministerium führt
mittlerweile auf seiner webseite mehr
als 100 laufende projekte auf dem gebiet
der quantentechnologie auf
quantencomputer endlich marktreif fehler
können jetzt weg gewählt werden denn
fehler sind immer noch ein großes
problem von quantencomputern und das
scheint jetzt gelöst worden zu sein also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren nicht
vergessen das geht mit dem abo button
unter jedem video bis dann bleibt dran